To help us investigate scopes,
let's write a program that helps us build zany sagas full of random words.
Each call that we make to a function in this program,
should help us string together a new combination of nouns and
verbs, adding one more sentence in an ongoing saga about a hero.
Once we start the program,
all the stories will be about this same hero that was randomly selected for us.
Each saga about this hero will feature a different randomly selected
foil character.
The program will call functions such that we string together a new
combination of nouns and verbs, adding one more sentence to this ongoing saga.
And that's it, it's a simple little program,
let's see how we could implement it using the feature of Scopes in JavaScript.